hat meine frau meine lieben freunde ich
und meine allerbesten freunde chantal
rosa kevin michael umschaden spielen
heute gemeinsam das 5 sekunden spiel
selbst erklärend deswegen würde ich
sagen wir statten auch direkt frage für
luca also mich karte aufdecken klicke
ich jetzt einfach mal ne ne 3 werben mit
h staaten halten hadern
humpeln
[Musik]
ich hab's geschafft frage für chantal
kommentar kompakter aufdecken in drei
haustiere spinne siegel
und mädchen
auch geschafft damit eine frage für rosa
es ist mir sowas geben muss eine karte
aufdecken nenne drei warme gerichte
trüffel nur den
champagner
[Musik]
junge mir sind keine drei warmen
gerichte eigene fallen ich muss halt
auch immer in der rolle denken frage für
kevin jüngste
[Musik]
müllkippen
derby
[Musik]
frage für michael markowitz world class
zimmer
[Musik]
beim alkohol frage für charlene
33 rohstoffe
rutsche für paprika
[Musik]
da war richtig geht allerdings direkt
weiter mit der zweiten runde wollen in
drei runden die wir bei diesem standard
deck hier heute mit dabei haben ich habe
noch zwei weitere lecks vorbereitet
wir decken karte für mich auf nenne drei
elemente des periodensystems wir haben
eisen schwefel und wasser sauerstoff
strahlung
habe ich geschafft stand nie wieder hin
3 hörte dem def anfang
[Musik]
flunder
wer bin ich wer würde drei fahrt hat die
mit j anfang juli meine eltern studierte
habe ich das ganze geld
für die kunden sind
ist voll schnee monate gewinn hier drei
farben schwarz rot gold die flagge von
frankreich
[Musik]
nach
wie vor gering
[Musik]
da marco von nene dringen mit beinen
badisch ein stuhlbein spiele
war richtig allerdings auch schon zur
letzten runde von dieser kategorie und
zwar eine frage an mich ne ne drei
prominente köche horse life michael
lichter und gordon ramsay
bern awp die vornamen richtig waren
trage fischern teil nenne drei dinge die
man flüstert lässt dann ist stille
poststelle mayer rosa 3 baumarten eiche
trifft
[Musik]
kann man sich mehr zeit kaufmann meinen
vater oder so gewinnen
die drei männer nahmen die mit ende
anfangen nina albert nußbaum
[Musik]
apple produkts apple juice
letzte frage für mich hinterher sorten
vanille
schokolade und gummibärchen
das blaue damit schrumpfen prag nicht
was mit mir los zeit da ich mich am
arsch das hier ist auf jeden fall das
finale ranking also luca hat geworden
ein problem leute ist nicht schlimm dass
er war total dumm sein kommt nun
allerdings zur zweiten kategorie die ich
für heute vorbereitet habe und zwar
nennen ein anderes wort für ich muss
jetzt meine karte aufdecken ein anderes
wort für beenden etwas fertig stellen
[Musik]
ich glaube luca wird wieder gewinnen
wenn ein anderes wort für sinnvoll sie
nicht
[Musik]
sinnig frage für rosa nenne ein anderes
wort so offen auf aufdecken
ich mir den sie kaufen können hier kann
man denn ein anderes wort für
vollständig
[Musik]
komplett
war noch in der zeit
mozarts letzte wort login namen the
world for giving up with
weil ein elfer
kurzem micro verteidiger
das wort für partner baby baby baby
aber ich dann meistens immer babytrage
für mich ne ne ein anderes wort für
letzter startet immer schnell
oder
letztens vor einiger zeit jedoch würde
ich mir ein punkt geben scheint teil der
coach ist denn ein anderes motto kreativ
künstlerisch
auf viele fragen wer möchte schon teil
so bist so kunstfertig
bernhard oder chantal sein frage für
rosa härter aufdecken in ein anderes
wort für lampe das ist die lichtquelle
[Musik]
in meinen palast zu hause haben wir über
unsere eltern
400.000 lichtquellen und wenn man alle
wechseln will legt man sich in drei
zeitzonen allein mein weg vom
kühlschrank zu meinem schlafzimmer da
muss ich meine uhr umstellen wenn unser
haus so groß ist
der abonnenten kann einer ich weiß nicht
was wenn wir diesem video heute gedacht
habt ihr wenn ihr locker nochmal dabei
sein kann ein anderes wort für seltsam
[Musik]
marco forster sogar kart namen the world
vor gesicht morgen
[Musik]
in building nehmen unsere wurzeln war
heiß oder seien einfach
ich bin heißt ja
kommt nun allerdings auch schon zur
letzten runde war heute meine lieben
freunde frage für mich direkt wieder
karten aufdecken nennen ein anderes wort
für qualm
rauch
abgas dunst dampf
ich bin mehrere punkte geben scheint
thailand in der kulturminister tragen
das wort zugeschickt
mai nicht mehr frisst wichtige frage
karczewski shisha bar frage für rosa
hand alles
jahren ein anderes wort für lernen alle
pauken
[Musik]
ich muss dich pauken mit eltern
sind
aufheben
ja
hallo
eine stunde später
eine bildschirmaufnahme ist abgebrochen
weil ich mein vater angerufen hat weil
irgendein juli in tschechien meine marke
angemeldet hat und ich jetzt 2000 euro
zahlen muss und wir jetzt vor gericht
gehen müssen
letzter tag im jahr noch mal eine
richtige scheiß nachricht bekommen
allerdings in der stadt ist heute wieder
zu beenden wenn die lieben freunde ich
weiß wie bereits gesagt nicht so richtig
was mir dabei heute gedacht habe ich
habe diese app neu entdeckt und dachte
mir da eine ganz geile idee mit freunden
die habe ich allerdings nicht deswegen
verkleide ich mich einfach und hey
vielleicht hat euch gefallen vielleicht
auch nicht lassen um hoch da wenn es das
getan hat abonniert meinen kanal und
klickt auf die glocke weiter will das
nicht verpassen will ich wünsche euch
einen wundervollen guten rutsch heute
abend treibt es nicht zu wild und
rutscht nicht